a crypto commodity is a token without an  issuer that cannot be manipulated by  some CEO or Corporation or other party  right there are crypto currencies like  tether and circle they are actually  tokens meant to represent the US dollar  or some other stable asset they have an  issuer and generally they're going to be  regulated as as Securities and as  currencies by the banking establishment  the SEC then there's crypto securities  Solana ftt serum those were all  Securities they had an issuer there were  companies behind them there were CEOs  behind them people could make more of  them people can destroy them there are  some people insiders that had  disproportionate interest in them those  could only be ethically sold to the  general public pursuant to a full and  fair disclosure